there was more reaction chairman of the
house oversight committee James Comer is
with us okay did that call Sir on
December 4th of 2015 take place with
Hunter with Barista Barista Partners in
Dubai to Joe Biden did that call take
place
yes five days our understanding five
days later on December 9th the Joe Biden
go to Ukraine and give a speech before
the parliament
yes he did is that the same day that Joe
Biden bragged about before the Council
of farm relations when he said uh you're
not getting a billion dollars uh you've
got six hours uh and you're going to
fire this prosecutor or I'm not giving
you the money is that the same day
that's it and that would be the day now
as a result of of that firing did his
son continue to be enriched financially
and get paid on the Barista board for a
job at a time he was a drug addict in a
time that he was also admitted in his
own words he had no experience in that
field at all
yes it was uh it's all a pattern here
Sean uh this is something we've been
talking about for a long time the
Democrats and their friends in the media
try to say there's no connection to Joe
Biden every day there's more connections
and I think these emails today are
consistent with the timeline that shows
exactly what the real quid pro quo was
in Ukraine it was Joe Biden not Donald
Trump the WhatsApp message is very
revealing I'm sitting here with my
father why didn't you keep your
commitment we expect a call from you uh
wasn't that uh wasn't that sent to a oil
executive with cefc the the Chinese
energy Giant
yes it was and remember that WhatsApp
message was produced by the IRS
whistleblowers this was the IRS
International tax crimes teams this was
the A-Team investigating all these
suspicious wires the suspicious activity
that the bidens were getting from
foreign Nationals around the world while
Joe biding was sitting vice president
influencing foreign policy that's why
the whistleblowers were so frustrated
when they were told to stand down
because they said their investigation
was clearly going straight to Joe Biden
let me ask you this that 1023 form that
the FBI desperately tried to keep from
you the one that used an FBI informant
and that informant was was trusted by
the FBI they had paid him hundreds of
thousands of dollars in the past right
so they believed in what he brought up
correct and they didn't want to give
this to you that's correct and you had a
copy and you and Charles Grassley
released it isn't that the same uh uh
informant that met with the CEO of
barisma and chronicled that conversation
and gave that information to the FBI and
in that information didn't it say that
that's where he said that he thought the
head of Barista said that he thought
Hunter was stupid his dog was smarter
but didn't they also say that he didn't
want to give the bidens money but he had
to was forced to 5 million for one Biden
5 million for another Biden and it will
take 10 years to find out how that money
was paid did that happen sir
yes sir and say you you look at that
1023 form that alleged the bribery it's
consistent with what we've seen in
Romania it's consistent with the
timeline that you and John Solomon have
documented on your show tonight and I
believe that one reason that Hunter was
cc'd on those emails where Joe Biden was
using a fake name is so Hunter could
prove to the Ukrainian oligarch look
help is on the way because we heard from
Devin Archer say that the the owners of
barisma were squeezing Hunter Biden
saying we need help from Washington now
who do you think they were referring to
when they were talking to Hunter Biden
who they've said was dumber than their
dogs who was a drug addict who had no
experience that we need help from
Washington who do you think they were
talking about and here we see now
evidence that shows Joe Biden didn't
have a wall between the government and
his son Shady business dealings he was
copying him on foreign policy to let him
know ahead of time help is on the way
we're going to go in there and we're
we're going to fire that prosecutor
who's trying to bust you for corruption
son and we're looking at a president of
the United States who's now being
investigated by your committee for
allegations of bribery and money
laundering is that a fair statement
that's a very fair statement
James Comer thank you for being with us
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else